pourquoi les voleurs se blottit les
catalyseurs le marché de la revente
explose depuis plusieurs années
notamment sur marketplace et pour
comprendre pourquoi on rencontre éric
veilleux en recycleur on va voir un psy
on a un super beau impreza de 2011 les
catalyseurs font partie du système
d'échappement d'un véhicule à essence
ils se trouvent parfois sous le capot
mais plus souvent il faut soulever le
véhicule
[Musique]
et voilà on est rendus sous note subaru
avec les bons outils la pièce est plutôt
simple acier et à voler pourquoi ça de
la valeur autant
l'importance et les métaux à l'intérieur
et hors du platine jeu rhodium du
palladium le prix de ces métaux a
explosé le propriétaire regarde
attentivement leurs évolutions sur les
marchés c'est partie d'à peu près 500
dollars de l'once en 2017 et ont atteint
en mars 2021
25000 quelque chose lors l'once toujours
au volant depuis une dizaine d'années le
prix de revente d'un catalyseur usagers
a doublé triplé et même quadruplé
passant parfois de 300 à 1200 dollars
tout dépend dans les modèles la valeur
se trouve à l'entrée à l'intérieur après
avoir recyclé les pièces eric se tourner
vers des acheteurs comme méthode de
récupération de métaux qui ont voix de
raffiner sa venue comme
marie-josé s'occupe du service à la
clientèle elle confirme l'appétit des
voleurs pour les catalyseurs non initiés
à notre entreprise on sait déjà faire
des français on sait pas de bol et un
vendeur doit prouver que le catalyseur
lui appartient avec son certificat
d'immatriculation et ceux qui voient les
catalyseurs sabots
les revendre ça peut être sur internet
il existe un dispositif à souder pour
protéger les catalyseurs mais peu de
garage offrent ce service au québec ici
alexis tremblay radio canada à
sherbrooke